hi my name is Harrison Ford and I feel
confused okay about being Conan
O'Brien's friend now listen
you and I talked about this a long time
ago we did and a lot of time has passed
you've made no effort whatsoever
and now you show up out of the blue
and you want me to be your friend yes I
do I do and listen what can you say on a
podcast you don't say anything you want
anything you like well you
favorite uh clearly uh Harrison you've
read the room and you understand that
there's a lot of animosity towards me
and that you will do quite well if you
on me throughout this process
thank you for confirming my instincts
you know the first thing you did when
you came in here is say I just want my
my parking validated
seems to be your Chief concern is that
we validate your parking when maybe I'm
going out on a limb here this could be
the biggest hour of your career it's
possible it's possible that this podcast
recording will outshine any of your
other work if he gets a parking
validation yeah
well don't worry about the car I'll walk
home
you will walk home run and suffer on air
yeah can we record you for the whole
walk home oh yeah sure thank you I want
to say something to you which is that I
have uh you you came on my show many
many times on The Late Night show and
over the years people would say who's
one of your favorite guests and I would
say Harrison Ford because he's so
goddamn funny you would come on the show
have you seen these appearances you are
so uh hilariously funny and you tossed
me around like a rag doll verbally on
these shows and they're some of my
favorite segments of all time you're a
hilarious man and I've always loved
being around you you guys wrote some
great
stuff for I remember uh I don't remember
right now
do you know who I am at this moment
yes
it's kind of cool when you say it that
way you know what it's only cool when
you say it it's the only time it's ever
been cool do it again
Conan
O'Brien yes wow it's like jazz yeah
that's fantastic
we're Jazzy yeah we all pick up on each
other he's Jazz you're you're uh he's
just like Carousel he's saying you're
Jazz I'm Jazz and I am uh yeah circus
Calliope yeah I think something kind of
that a chimp would dance to and you're
Chas
okay I'm sure all right what kind of her
name is Conan is it uh how dare you uh
Conan is a an old Gaelic name that my
parents gave me uh they thought we'll
call him Gaelic I come from do you speak
Gaelic I do not I do not speak Gaelic in
fact I don't think anybody really speaks
Gaelic I think it's a made-up uh have
you heard Gaelic it sounds like a bunch
of someone threw some chairs Down The
Back Stairs
it's just a lot of
you know consonants there's not a vowel
in there and I think it's just to
confuse people about when it's time to
go to the pub so I uh I don't speak
Gaelic but I do have a very Irish name
and um you know what fascinated me to
learn I'm part Irish you are part Irish
yeah Irish German and uh mother Jewish
what's the German part that I thought
you were German Irish I thought your dad
was germanized is there such a thing as
German Irish sure yeah would German
people were allowed to marry Irish
people sure
but you don't carry a designation by
marrying somebody a a national I'm
that's sure you do you know there are
Irish Italians okay of course my father
is was uh uh Irish Irish right okay no
German no German no okay I refer you to
this piece of paper right here that says
born and raised in Chicago to an Irish
slash German father well that's if
that's a quality of your research
and I imagine is because right there it
says Harrison Ford and then you had to
write down Han Solo yeah I did you can't
remember that no I can't
can't remember Han Solo are you serious
yeah I wrote down because I heard that
you were in some of the Star Wars films
and this was news to me because I've
seen those films and I don't exactly
think you pop well you I didn't
recognize I'm sorry whoa but I mean I
remember Chewbacca
I remember uh the bad guy with the black
helmet and then there's some people how
come you're not still on television
laughs
I think it's quite obvious why I'm not
still on television yeah